Sur les rivages d'Acapulco, la célèbre cité balnéaire mexicaine,
Une soixantaine d'hommes gagnent leur vie en
jouant les intrépides, du haut de cette falaise.
On est prêts !
Un peu nerveux mais on va plonger de la falaise.
À 35 mètres de hauteur, chaque saut peut être fatal.
Ces plongeurs de l'extrême habitent les
quartiers pauvres, dans les hauteurs de la ville.
Allez, on va recevoir la bénédiction.
José trompe la mort depuis 30 ans et il a
initié toute sa famille à ce métier hors du commun.
La mère de José ne les laisse jamais partir au travail,
Attends, attends ! Tu vas nous donner la bénédiction.
Après, on doit y aller.
Sans ses baisers protecteurs.
Que Dieu te vienne en aide.
Au nom du Père, du Fils et du Saint Esprit, Amen.
Je demande beaucoup à la Vierge et à Dieu pour que tout aille bien.
Je lui demande qu'elle les protège lors
de leurs plongeons parce que c'est dangereux.
Je suis toujours très émue et très fière de toute la famille.
Que Dieu soit avec vous, que la Vierge vous protège.
Même après 30 ans d'expérience, José, le père de famille,
garde l'appréhension de ses débuts dans le métier.
On a quand même toujours le vertige, la peur de l'altitude.
Le vrai risque, quand tu rentres dans
l'eau, c'est de te cogner et de te blesser.
Un, deux, trois.
José et les siens ne plongent pas devant les touristes
par plaisir. C'est leur seul moyen de gagner de l'argent.
Le premier saut se déroule à 28 mètres du sol.
José n'a pas sauté à l'aveugle, loin de là. Avant
de s'élancer, les plongeurs attendent la vague.
Elle fait passer le fonds de 4 à 6 mètres, deux petits mètres
qui évitent qu'ils ne s'écrasent au fond de l'océan.
Une fois sous l'eau, les plongeurs opèrent un virage rapide.
Bizarrement, quand sa fille Iris a commencé le métier,
Pour José, le plus dangereux n'était pas
qu'elle se jette dans le vide.
La première fois que je suis venue ici
voir mon papa, j'avais quatre ou cinq ans.
J'ai vu ce qu'il faisait et j'ai aimé ça.
Je voulais imiter mon papa.
J'avais peur qu'elle tombe. Le plus
dangereux, c'est d'escalader en fait.
C'est plus difficile de grimper sur les rochers que de plonger.
C'est au tour de son gendre, Alexis, de s'élancer.
Mais cette fois-ci de 35 mètres, soit
la hauteur d'un immeuble de dix étages.
Quand tu arrives en haut, les pieds au bord
du précipice, tu ressens la peur et le stress.
Et tu espères que tout se passera bien.
Alexis entre dans l'eau à près de 90 km/h.
67 plongeurs se partagent la falaise depuis plus de 80 ans.
En 1934, on a commencé à sauter de un mètre,
deux mètres et le public leur lançait des pièces.
On n'est pas beaucoup à se lancer de cette
falaise tête la première. C'est une tradition.
Aujourd'hui, pour moi, c'est devenu un travail. Je subviens
aux besoins de ma famille, mes enfants, ma mère,
Tout le monde en profite.
J'essaie de faire du mieux possible.
Le Mexique est la huitième puissance commerciale du monde.
Le pays a de nombreuses ressources, pétrole, gaz, minerais.
Mais ils ne sont qu'une poignée à profiter de ses richesses.
Ces inégalités sont flagrantes à Mexico.
La capitale est débordée par ses 20 millions d'habitants.
Une grande partie de la population vit dans la misère.
Cherchant à survivre par tous les moyens
dans cette mégapole à deux vitesses.
Pour échapper à la pauvreté, cet homme exerce
un métier aussi dangereux que repoussant.
Il est scaphandrier dans les égouts de Mexico.
Dans les campagnes, certains travaillent
toute une vie comme des forçats pour s'en sortir.
Cette famille de briquetiers se tue à la tâche pour
un rêve, celui d'un avenir meilleur pour les plus jeunes.
Ma fille veut continuer à étudier. Si Dieu
veut qu'elle réussisse ses études, tant mieux.
Plonger avec ses hommes forts et courageux,
prêts à donner leur vie pour une poignée de pesos.
Mexico est l'une des villes les plus polluées du monde.
La capitale, est incapable de faire face aux
tonnes de déchets issus d'une démographie galopante.
L'eau potable, elle-même, est contaminée par les eaux usées
qui s'échappent d'un réseau vétuste, d'un autre temps.
Les machines seules ne parviennent pas à combattre ce fléau.
Un homme plonge quotidiennement dans les égouts
pour nettoyer les pompes obstruées par les déchets.
Vérifie la pression des bouteilles s'il te plaît.
Les batteries, l'eau, le cordon, les crochets...
Julio César Camara, 55 ans, est le
scaphandrier des égouts de Mexico,
Un métier unique au monde.
Dans cette station de drainage, il y a beaucoup de poubelles, donc on va vérifier ça, surtout après toute la pluie qu'il y a eu.
On va faire une inspection.
Le drainage des égouts de la ville de
Mexico, c'est vraiment spectaculaire.
C'est une grande œuvre d'art des ingénieurs.
Le problème, c'est les poubelles.
Si ici à Mexico, on ne jetait pas les poubelles
dans la rue, il n'y aurait jamais d'inondations.
On n'aurait pas besoin de déboucher.
L'eau coulerait sans aucun problème.
Ces collecteurs d'eaux usées sont de vrais bouillon de culture.
Cette eau est dangereuse. Il y a de tout dans cette eau.
Des déchets chimiques, des animaux, des humains.
Cette eau est trop polluée. Si je n'utilisait
pas ce scaphandre, cette combinaison sèche,
Je me mouillerai et j'avalerai de l'eau.
Ce serait presque ma mort assurée !
- Prêt ?
- Prêt.
Je suis un peu nerveux, je ne sais jamais ce que je vais trouver.
Allez, on descend !
Tu m'entends bien ?
- Oui.
- Allez on descend.
On a cherché, mais je n'ai jamais trouvé. Personne
au monde ne plonge dans les égouts comme moi.
Prêt ?
Allez, on y va !
Je te monte un peu la pression.
Elle est à 130.
Mets-la à 140.
Lâche un peu de cordon pour qu'il
ne s'emmêle pas avec la cage.
OK. On s'en occupe.
Un cordon ombilical lui permet de respirer
et de communiquer avec la surface.
Je suis sorti de la cage.
J'ai besoin que tu me diriges.
Va sur ta droite.
Tu es en train de revenir !
Oui, ouin j'y retourne.
Il y a quelque chose qui gêne sur le filtre ?
- Attends, j'essaie de me maintenir en bas.
- OK, reçu.
Le récurage se fait par 18 mètres de profondeur.
Je scrute, j'ai trouvé des pierres...
Ces pierres se sont formées par réaction chimique
quand ils ont traité les eaux des égouts.
Ici, on est un peu stressé parce que lui est
sous l'eau et on ne peut pas savoir ce qui se passe.
On ne sait pas comment il se sent donc il continue
à parler pour qu'on sache tout le temps qu'il va bien.
S'il arrête de parler, c'est qu'il lui arrive quelque chose.
Souvent, il chante et comme ça, il nous
rassure et nous transmet sa confiance,
Et on sait que tout va bien.
- Tu veux que je te chante une chanson ?
- Oui mais une qui me plaît.
- Laquelle tu veux, alors ?
- Celle qui fait genre "sous l'océan".
Celle de la Petite Sirène.
Mais je ne la connais pas bien celle-là.
Ce n'est pas sous la mer, c'est sous les égouts !
- Arrête-toi, tu y es.
- Attends. J'écris mon nom.
Tout ce que vous pouvez imaginer, je l'ai trouvé là-dessous.
Ce qui m'a le plus impressionné, c'est une tête de cochon.
Elle faisait quatre, cinq mètres d'épaisseur car elle avait gonflé.
J'ai aussi trouvé des carcasses de voitures.
Des appareils électroménagers.
On trouve de tout ici.
Julio, reste rarement plus de 20 minutes au fond des égouts.
J'étais mieux dans l'eau qu'ici.
Vas-y, fais-nous un petit plongeon.
Après chaque plongée, l'équipement est désinfecté. Aucune
goutte de cette eau sale ne doit entrer en contact avec sa peau.
Ce qui me fait le plus peur dans mon travail,
c'est que le cordon se casse et que je n'ai plus d'air.
Ça, c'est un des gros problèmes que je peux rencontrer.
Je peux rester coincé ou un gros objet
peut me tomber sur la tête. Le travail est dur.
Physiquement, très dur.
Sa prochaine plongée va se dérouler dans une zone qu'affectionnent les tueurs de Mexico, pour dissimuler leurs cadavres.
À 500 kilomètres de là, sur les falaises d'Acapulco, les plongeurs de haute voltige prennent soin de leur outil de travail.
Allez stop, les pieds et les genoux joints. Les mains...
Iris, 22 ans, la fille de José, joue les coachs sportifs.
Même s'il a de l'expérience, José est vigilant
avec son corps. À 45 ans, il n'a plus la même force.
On arrête de plonger quand on pense qu'on a pris trop de poids,
Qu'on devient trop vieux.
L'impulsion doit le propulser à trois ou cinq mètres de la falaise.
Avec l'âge, on n'a plus la force.
Rester concentré. Ne jamais dévier.
Et entretenir sa musculature comme une armure,
sont les règles pour rester en vie.
Le corps d'athlète d'Iris, la sûrement sauvée après
une mauvaise réception lors d'un plongeon à 28 mètres.
Je me suis blessée au dos, à la colonne vertébrale.
Donc j'ai peur de plonger et de ne plus pouvoir marcher.
Ma chute a été forte. Ma colonne a fait comme un accordéon.
Tous les muscles de mon dos ont enflé. Maintenant, plonger,
c'est trop dangereux pour moi. Je risque d'être handicapé à vie.
Au quotidien, les petits bobos sont nombreux.
Après l'entraînement, José accompagne son fils chez le médecin.
Le jeune homme de 19 ans s'est blessé en plongeant.
La salle d'attente rappelle à José le pire accident qu'il ait eu.
Une fois, j'ai touché des pierres au fond de l'eau et je
me suis fait une entaille ici d'au moins 10 centimètres.
C'était impressionnant. Une plaie ouverte de dix centimètres.
Mais on n'a eu que des petites
blessures, jamais d'accidents mortels.
Son fils plonge au minimum 70 fois par semaine.
Un régime intensif qui met ses tympans à rude épreuve.
Pourquoi consultez-vous aujourd'hui ?
J'ai très mal à l'oreille, j'ai eu un accident en plongeant hier.
Que s'est-il passé ?
Oui, c'est mon tympan qui est enflammé.
Je ne peux plus manger. C'est toute la mâchoire.
- Vous êtes plongeur ?
- Oui, il est professionnel.
Plongeur, une vieille histoire de famille.
Dans les années 30, le père de José faisait
lui-même partie des premiers voltigeurs d'Acapulco.
Ça, c'est mon père. C'est mon papa quand il a plongé pour la dernière fois, c'était le 60ᵉ anniversaire de la falaise.
Ça, c'était lors d'un championnat de jeunes.
Mon frère a gagné. Moi, je suis
arrivé deuxième et lui là troisième.
Ici, c'est ma fille Iris, quand elle a battu le record Guinness.
Parce que c'était la plus jeune à plonger de 18 mètres.
Pour moi, ce fut une surprise qu'on me donne ce livre.
Et je ne savais pas non plus que le gouverneur allait
venir et me remettre un prix, entourée de toute ma famille.
Le dernier né de la famille, Yan, 10 mois, a un avenir tout tracé. Même si son père Alexis aimerait changer le destin familial.
J'aimerais bien voir mon fils plonger
mais en même temps, ça me fait peur.
Franchement, je ne souhaite pas le voir plonger de 28 ou
35 mètres. C'est quelque chose que je n'espère vraiment pas.
Je pense qu'il vaudrait mieux qu'il
étudie et choisisse un autre sport.
Alexis est devenu l'un des meilleurs plongeurs d'Acapulco.
Il a pris la relève de son beau-père, José.
A 19h30, ça commence, c'est 40 pesos par personne.
- Deux places ?
- Il n'y a pas de réduction ?
Non, c'est pour tout le monde pareil.
Trop vieux pour plonger tous les jours, José
n'assure plus le spectacle qu'un jours sur deux.
Le reste du temps, il gère la billetterie auprès des touristes.
Ici à Acapulco, le tourisme est saisonnier.
En ce moment, pendant les vacances d'été, ça marche un peu mieux.
On peut arriver à gagner entre 100 et 150€ en quinze jours.
Mais en saison basse, on gagne environ 80€.
Ça dépend du nombre de spectateurs.
Ce soir là, Alexis, le beau fils de José,
a le privilège de clore le spectacle.
Salut les amis, bienvenue !
Les plongeurs assurent cinq show par jour.
Le dernier aura lieu en pleine nuit.
Tout va bien ! Un peu nerveux, mais ça va.
Ce soir, c'est Alexis qui aura le privilège de
réaliser l'ultime plongeon nocturne. Le plus dangereux.
C'est aussi le plus rentable. Alexis va,
grâce à ce saut, récolter la moitié des pourboires.
19h. Sur l'air de Mission Impossible, les 9-12 ans
ouvrent le spectacle avec des sauts à 18 mètres.
Suit le périlleux plongeon en tandem à 28 mètres de hauteur.
C'est l'heure du saut à 35 mètres.
Avant de s'élancer, Alexis attend la vague et ces deux mètres d'eau supplémentaires qui l'empêche de s'écraser sur les rochers.
C'est vraiment spectaculaire.
Mais c'est vraiment très dangereux. Ils le font tellement bien !
C'est des professionnels.
Bonjour les amis, nous sommes
le groupe de plongeurs de haut vol.
On est là si vous avez des questions, des doutes.
Si vous voulez nous laisser
un petit pourboire pour notre travail.
Donnez ce que vous voulez.
Merci l'ami. Merci pour ta visite.
Ça ne te fait pas peur de te jeter de tout en haut ?
Si, ça fait peur, c'est stressant, il y a de l'adrénaline,
Mais on s'habitue à vivre avec l'adrénaline et la peur.
Avec le temps, on s'y fait.
Je te dis pas que la peur disparaît complètement
mais un peu quand même.
Alexis est avenant avec les touristes.
Se prête au jeu des photos. Souris.
Mais le risque paie de moins en moins. En tout
et pour tout, il a gagné 2,50€ de pourboire.
Le jeune homme espère bien se rattraper avec les sauts de nuit.
Devant le danger que représentent ces plongeons sans
visibilité, les touristes sont souvent plus généreux.
Je prie la Vierge pour qu'il ne m'arrive rien.
Je prie aussi pour mes collègues, pour que les plongeons
se passent bien et qu'il n'y ait pas de problème.
Si quelque chose de mauvais devait arriver, je lui demande qu'elle nous protège pour que l'accident ne soit pas trop grave.
Je suis content ! Tout s'est bien passé !
Une fois de plus, je suis en vie !
Je peux recommencer. Je suis prêt à faire un autre plongeon.
En additionnant les pourboires des cinq sauts de la journée,
Alexis a gagné 10€. De quoi nourrir sa famille.
Certains plongeurs, eux, sont obligés de
cumuler plusieurs métiers pour survivre.
À 200 kilomètres de Mexico, des hommes soulèvent
des tonnes de terre à la force des bras.
Dans les montagnes de l'État de Guerrero, les
faiseurs de briques n'arrête jamais de travailler.
La dureté du travail se retrouve à chaque
étape de la fabrication qui commence à l'aube.
Ici, rien n'a changé depuis 11 000 ans.
Les gestes de ces ouvriers sont les mêmes que leurs
ancêtres aztèques. À part peut être la brouette.
Javier, 45 ans, et le propriétaire de cette briqueterie.
C'est le début du travail. Il faut creuser la boue.
Après, on l'emporte dans les puits où on fait le mélange.
Ça, c'est vraiment dur.
Tu passes toute la journée à piocher.
Confectionner des briques demande plusieurs étapes exténuantes.
Après avoir récupéré la terre, il faut la mélanger
à de la sciure pour qu'elle reste compacte.
Puis, une fois moulée, il faut attendre qu'elle sèche en la retournant sur chaque face, et ce, sur des milliers de briques.
Pour ces hommes, la fatigue est permanente.
On retourne la terre. C'est 5 à 6 passages.
On le fait six fois. Ça aussi, c'est vraiment dur.
Beaucoup se blesse avec cette houe.
Et même se coupe des orteils.
Quand tu n'as pas l'habitude ou que tu ne fais pas gaffe.
Une fois les briques sèches, Javier et ses
hommes les empilent pour constituer un four.
Un petit édifice de 20 000 briques.
On n'arrête pas de bosser toute la journée.
En fin d'après-midi, ça commence vraiment
à faire mal au dos. Ça fait mal.
C'est très fatigant.
Ça fait plus de 20 ans que je fais ce
travail tous les jours. 20, 22 ans.
Je connais ce travail depuis que je suis tout petit.
C'est mon père qui m'a appris.
Depuis l'âge de dix ou douze ans, je suis ici et j'aide mon père.
La construction du four leur prend près d'une semaine.
C'est un travail très noble.
On ne gagne pas beaucoup, mais au moins on n'a
pas besoin de partir ailleurs pour chercher du travail,
Et subvenir aux besoins de sa famille. On est ici tous ensemble.
Dès qu'il revient de l'école, Juan, son jeune
fils, donne un coup de main à la briqueterie.
Seule Brigitte, la petite dernière, échappe à cette corvée.
Elvira, sa femme, quant à elle, ne fait plus que de menus travaux.
Quand j'ai commencé, je l'aidais à porter des briques. J'avais mal aux hanches, j'avais trop chaud. C'est dur pour une femme.
On s'est connus à l'école.
Il m'a invité ici, à sa briqueterie, au travail de son papa.
C'est là qu'on a commencé à être ensemble.
Le travail se fait en groupe.
Les enfants, moi, on ne l'a jamais laissé tout seul.
Tous ensemble.
Tout le monde y met son petit grain de sable.
Il est 11h30. On va manger ? Il est tard.
Javier est levé depuis 6h du matin.
Le déjeuner est la seule pause de sa journée.
De ce travail, il ne tire qu'une seule satisfaction.
Ici, nous avons au moins l'avantage d'être propriétaires.
Le terrain nous appartient, on ne paye pas de loyer.
Tout ce qu'il y a ici, je l'ai fait moi-même.
Les matériaux, les murs...
Tout ce qui est ici grâce à Dieu, c'est nous qui l'avons fait.
Une vie à la dure, sans électricité et sans eau courante.
L'état de Guerrero est l'un des plus pauvres du Mexique.
Les infrastructures sont quasiment inexistante.
Javier et les autres briquetiers de la
région ont dû créer leur propre réseau d'eau.
Seul problème, les familles doivent se partager les tuyaux.
Je vais monter là-haut pour connecter le tuyau d'arrivée d'eau.
Et l'utiliser pour la cuisine.
Deux fois par semaine, Javier parcourt deux
kilomètres en montagne pour se raccorder à la source.
Voilà le tuyau part d'ici.
On le connecte et ça coule directement jusqu'à la maison.
Depuis quelques années, Javier n'est plus tranquille.
Il doit faire face à un fléau qui ravage
sa région et le met en péril, lui et sa famille.
Les cartels de la drogue s'installent dans ses montagnes pour cultiver la **** et le pavot qu'il transforme en ****.
La criminalité a envahi la région.
Tout ce qu'on voit là-bas, ce sont des briqueteries
qui appartiennent aux gens du village.
Des délinquants de la région sont venus nous extorquer de l'argent.
À nous, les fabricants de briques.
Trois jeunes se sont fait enlever.
Les ravisseurs ont demandé une rançon à leur famille.
Deux de ces jeunes ont disparu et se sont fait tuer.
En tout cas, on ne les a jamais retrouvés.
Depuis ces événements, les habitants du village ont
formé une milice et se protègent comme ils peuvent.
Le Guerrero est devenu la région la plus dangereuse du Mexique.
Il n'y a pourtant pas grand chose à voler, même les
jours de vente, les caisses sont loin d'être pleines.
Ils viennent chercher les briques.
Le prix d'une brique, c'est 7 centimes.
Les 1000, c'est 70€.
C'est minimum 20 000 briques par four.
Après avoir payé les employés,
La main d'oeuvre, il nous reste environ 265€.
Son travail de force l'éreinte pour trois
fois moins que le salaire moyen mexicain.
Mais toute cette sueur lui permettra
peut-être de réaliser le rêve de toute une vie.
À Mexico, Julio, le Scaphandrier gagne un salaire
beaucoup plus confortable de 1 000€ par mois.
Mais son paysage à lui est fait d'ordures et d'immondices.
Julio débute une immersion en eaux
troubles particulièrement éprouvante.
La zone à explorer est tellement infestée
qu'il doit travailler à l'aveugle.
- Tout va bien ?
- Tout va bien.
Tu as l'air très agité.
Je suis en train de pousser sur...
Il y a un chiffon, quelque chose qui ressemble à une serpillère.
Il y a une sorte de longue tige.
OK. Remonte-moi.
- Tu me dis.
- Monte, monte, monte.
Stop, redescends-moi, comme ça j'enlève tous ces détritus.
Allez, vas-y, redescends-moi.
Ça, c'est le travail quotidien pour que ces grilles
fonctionnent correctement. C'est ça qui bloquait.
C'est ces gros bouts de bois qui
gênaient la fermeture de la grille.
Faire ce travail et pouvoir enlever toutes
ces poubelles, je trouve ça très gratifiant.
Parce que je sais que grâce à mon travail, le
drainage de la ville de Mexico se fera un peu mieux.
Pour moi, c'est un vrai plaisir de faire ce boulot.
Cette eau est complètement contaminée avec de tout.
Des animaux comme ce rat par exemple.
Tout est contaminé.
Ces animaux transmettent des maladies dangereuses.
Allez, on monte.
On trouve aussi des corps humains. Souvent,
on les tue ailleurs et on vient les jeter ici.
Allez, c'est bon. Stop.
Ils les jettent dans les égouts et nous, on est juste
en train de travailler et il faut qu'on les sorte.
En 30 ans de carrière, Julio s'est retrouvé
sous l'eau face à plusieurs corps humains.
Cette violence n'est pas réservée à Mexico.
Elle s'étend un peu partout dans le pays.
José et sa famille de plongeurs de haut vol n'ont
pas les moyens de vivre uniquement de leur talent.
Avec les collègues, quand il n'y a pas
trop de touristes. Des fois, on sort pêcher.
Tous les poissons qu'on ramène, c'est pour
nourrir la famille, femme, enfants, tout le monde.
J'ai quelques collègues qui pêchent
toute la nuit ou toute la journée,
Et qui vendent le poisson pour ramener de l'argent à la maison.
La famille de José, comme celle de Javier, le briquetier,
sont les victimes collatérales de la guerre de la drogue,
Et des morts qu'elle provoque.
Au moment de notre tournage, Acapulco comptait depuis
le début de l'année près de 500 morts par homicide.
Un poisson, c'est tout ?
Deux !
On y va.
La criminalité, a fait fuir les bateaux de croisière.
En dix ans, ils sont passés de 180 à 3 ou quatre par saison.
Les bateaux de croisières ne viennent plus à cause
de l'idée qu'on se fait du Mexique,
Qui est lié à la violence et aux crimes organisés.
Les gens ont peur. Les Américains ne viennent plus.
Pas seulement à Acapulco, mais dans tout le Mexique.
Aujourd'hui, les forces de l'ordre
reprennent peu à peu le contrôle de la ville.
Les touristes reviennent petit à petit.
Le sourire de José aussi.
L'après-midi, ça fait du bien de passer un bon moment en famille.
C'est vraiment agréable. C'est pour des moments
comme ça qu'on est prêt à prendre autant de risques.
Chez les plongeurs, il n'y a jamais eu de crise de vocations.
Les sensations fortes, les montées d'adrénaline se
transmettent de père en fils depuis près de 80 ans.
Un air de fête plane sur la briqueterie. Javier
et sa femme ont sorti leurs plus beaux habits.
Ils vont assister à la remise de diplômes du
passage en sixième d'une petite cousine.
Une fierté dans la famille.
On y va.
Leurs trois fils n'ont jamais brillé dans les études. Deux ont quitté l'école très jeune et le dernier est en passe de le faire.
Javier et sa femme espèrent que leur
fille suivra les traces de sa cousine.
Ma fille veut continuer à étudier.
On en a parlé avec toute la famille. On va la soutenir au maximum. Si Dieu veut qu'elle réussisse ses études, tant mieux.
La plupart des gens qui sont ici travaillent dans les briqueteries.
Les autres sont agriculteurs. Ils font pousser du piment
ou du maïs, mais la plupart vivent grâce aux briques.
Mais l'avenir s'annonce sombre.
Deux de ses garçons travaillent avec lui.
Javier aimerait qu'il continue le métier,
Seulement, le filon d'argile commence à s'épuiser.
Je dis à mes fils,
Que ce serait mieux pour eux, qu'ils apprennent un autre métier.
Ce serait un peu mieux. Car le terrain
ici où travaille la famille, c'est fini.
Mais ce n'est pas grave. On peut chercher autre chose
ailleurs. Louer un terrain, même si on gagne moins.
Tant pis.
La cuisson des briques est la dernière étape de la fabrication.
Devant cette tour de Babel, son fils
Éléazar, 19 ans, se prend à rêver.
Je n'ai pas d'avenir ici.
Pour dire vrai, j'ai d'autres projets. J'aime bien le bétail.
J'aimerais un jour avoir un petit Ranch.
J'aime bien les chevaux. Je voudrais m'en occuper.
Je n'aime pas le travail à la briqueterie.
Si Dieu le veut, j'aurai mon petit Ranch.
Là, dès qu'on a allumé le feu, il n'y a plus de repos.
Ça brûle entre 24 et 36h, parfois même jusqu'à 40 heures !
C'est usant de passer toute la nuit sans dormir. C'est fatigant.
Ma vie est ici, tout simplement.
J'ai toujours travaillé comme ça.
Si Dieu le veut, je vais continuer à
vivre et à travailler dans la construction.
Jusqu'à la fin, on travaillera.